good morning ladies and gentlemen and
welcome to the press conference
following this special meeting of the
European Council on brexit without
further ado I first invited the
President of the European Council
Thanatos to take the floor
thank you with the president dear
friends tonight the European Council
decided to grant the United Kingdom a
flexible extension of the article 50
period until the 31st of October this
means an additional six months for the
UK during this time the cause of action
will be entirely in the UK's hands it
can still ratify the Royal agreement in
which case the extension will be
terminated it can also reconsider the
whole bracket strategy that might lead
to changes in the political declaration
but not in the withdrawal agreement
until the end of this period the UK will
also have the possibility to revoke
article 50 and council brings it all
together the UK will continue sincere
cooperation as a full member state with
all its rights and as a close friend and
trusted ally in the future let me finish
with a message to our British friends
this extension is as flexible as I
expected and a little bit shorter than I
expected but it's still enough to find
the best possible solution please do not
waste this time thank you thank you and
now president Juncker of the European
Commission oui Bonjour
[Music]
Rini
with the agreements that models are good
because I get the rest with your aunt
agreement
you
Irish friends so they will probably be
European election at noon item they sing
their rules let's respect your opinion
then we will see what do I do rather
regret talk about breakfast I read the
brick European practice this morning
president reached an agreement know what
I mean it's true after all
from outside its the tweet for matters
relating to promoted and insufficiently
focus agreement it has been more iike
madona mallets the 20 separate I think
it was essentially 27 is there is in
there now this
and in the action and in October we'll
continue our meeting thank you
and the floor is now open for your
questions and I think the first question
goes to Chris yes the gentleman to all
right Thank You Burton is Chris Morrison
BBC and president us you said the
extension was a little shorter than you
expected isn't it from your perspective
in some ways the worst of both worlds
not short enough to really put on the
pressure in the UK Parliament to get a
deal passed quickly but not long enough
to allow you to set aside brexit to
focus on other things for any useful
period of time and secondly as you know
article 50 says nothing or doesn't rule
out multiple extensions is there
anything in the language agreed today
which says October the 31st is the final
deadline or is it possible that come
mid-october mid to late October we will
once again be having a summit like this
and working out how much longer we're
going to extend again piece of something
then I love nothing and which means that
in six months more than six months and
almost three weeks it's it could be
enough for a good solution if this
goodwill and and majority for some
solutions in but in London a person in
the House of Commons general I'm
satisfied because it's if you know not
only the today's discussion but also our
preparations showed that the this idea
of flexible extension was not so obvious
for some our partners and this is why I
think we have to be maybe not happy but
satisfied by this by the solution our
intention is to finalize the whole
process in October
but mmm and the political intention was
clear among the member states that our
[Music]
evaluations our hope is that the UK will
be ready with with the final solution in
the end of October but I'm too old to
exclude another scenario we said I think
it's still everything is possible and
the second question was will be a total
disaster well knows that so we have to
do everything to avoid a hearty that's
what Anand I myself are trying to do
till now we have been quite successful
I like the decision we have taken - not
tonight because the ante has been fixed
on the 31 of October I have to leave my
job on the 1st of November this year so
my guess would be that we will have not
a night session because if we had I have
to leave the meeting at midnight
thank you and I think yes the gentleman
to our left was next Jim thank you good
morning Jim Bronstein from the Financial
Times
if October is now the deadline and if as
as you have said president asked the the
course of affairs is now fully in the
UK's hands between now and then what is
the point of this review that's been
discussed for for June what why are we
having this and what can take place on
that occasion if everything is now in
London it must be clear this assessment
or reviewing journeys only to update us
on the progress when it comes to
ratification process and and the legal
processes in in the UK this June is not
for for for decisions about extension or
and my intention is not even not to
discuss but only to inform the member
states about the current situation and
fair
in June we are taking stock of what has
happened from now to Dan it's not a
negotiation session it's not another
cliff as we would insert in the normal
program as far as our programs are
normal they are not but we have don't
have the intention to negotiate in June
the real moment the moment of the vital
moment of decision is October in June we
take stock
preparing the meeting will have little
in October
June is not a cliff edge moment for to
take me decisions that it must be clear
thank you and we'll take one last
question yes gentlemen in the middle
Nicholson orders from Bloomberg News can
I ask you to elaborate on paragraphs 7
and 8 of the today's decision what do
you expect from the UK what do you mean
by Cisco cooperation do you expect the
UK to not participate for example in the
votes for high-level appointments in
June what exactly is the theater that
you expect and the second question if I
may given the differences today over the
length of extension do you insist that
the unity of the 2007 still holds or did
France go rogue today
sincere cooperation is sincere
cooperation and we have only good two
experiences with resumes government when
it comes to the loyalty to our rules and
principles Ian in Brussels and there's
no any kind of intention to establish a
new format for member state and the
article 50 and of course the United
Kingdom is and will remain during the
whole process from member Union no doubt
with all the obligations but also with
all the rights and especially with
voting right no no doubts but our
intention was to have some you know
political guarantees and decorations
that the UK will not use any any kind of
political blocking so tricks and to stop
our work or to use this possibility as a
political instrument to impulse
something and I think well I I trust
what some may declare today and I have
no doubt that that this term sincere
cooperation is treated seriously the
reference to sincere cooperation is a
reference to the basic principle of the
treaties which are governing our living
together and I trust which I made that
the United Kingdom will not step away
from the treaty obligation they have to
cooperate with the other member states
yes yeah lawyer way I know that in parts
of Europe
sometimes in Britain too there is this
idea that Britain could block
in the next coming years decisions of
the European Union we had heard voices
coming from within that the Britain
wants to be a very different partner of
the others that's nothing new the other
point is that we should dramatize this
issue because the next big decisions we
have to take appointment of the
president of European Council of the one
of the European Commission and others
can be dealt with with qualified
majority even trade treaties have to be
dealt with and can be dealt with and
must be dealt with if necessary by
qualified majority voting so the
possibilities for Britain to block
decisions are very very limited so I
wanted just to add this to two remarks
of the present 27 unity we are united
enough to have a common conclusions and
this is unity doesn't mean that we
always I mean all 27 or 28 member states
on the same and identical position but
unity in our case means that we are
always able to to find a compromise and
this this was this that case will have
the bracket with a deal I would have
preferred a deal without package they're
much easier to build majority here or
even unity then in the House of Commons
in which I repeat II must help by saying
that the Sphinx is an open book by
comparison to the British Parliament
thank you this concludes the press
conference good night